[Musik]
wir sind zu dem schluss gekommen dass
ein teil der gewinne aus dem verkauf
nigerianischen öls an den start ging
juni wenn das sata der lust an
alkohol einige der erträge aus dem
ölverkauf gegen an die privatunternehmen
atlantic energy & southern energy
so gelangte geld das für den staat
bestimmt war in die hände privater
firmen
[Musik]
diese absprachen sind verfassungswidrig
und illegal
[Musik]
ich habe mehrfach versucht die familie
anzurufen erreichte aber niemanden
also bin ich persönlich für ein
interview mit herrn luckow gekommen
ich kann mal nachfragen
es war noch winter als ich mit der suche
nach kohle alu begann dem öl magnaten
der sowohl von nigerianischen wie
britischen behörden gesucht wurde weil
er gemeinsam mit ölminister die sani
angeblich die gewinne der ölvorkommen
seines landes ins ausland geschmuggelt
hatte
2 1 liter lupo jedoch in dieser
luxuriösen villa im porzer mit
wunderbaren ausblick auf dem luganersee
und in der schweiz wurde er nicht
strafrechtlich verfolgt
auf nachfrage bekam ich die antwort er
gebe aktuell keine interviews ich habe
die verantwortlichen informiert
sollen wir waren anders wiederkommen es
wieder versuchen
hatte ein kontaktbüro
nicht hier
wo genau kann ich nicht so ich sage nur
so viel es ist nicht einfach zu finden
wird seine die sitzende offshore-firmen
treue freunde in hollywood eine yacht in
der karibik villen und apartments von
los angeles bis new york abbas und eine
leidenschaft für rennwagen
[Musik]
seinen rennanzug ein traum denn an dem
kessel team in grunge erfüllung ging für
dear auf berühmten strecken rennen fuhr
er
fährt ferrari es aber nicht nur er
sammelt sie auch in einer kessel garage
in lugano stehen möglicherweise dutzende
autos auch aus der formel 1 im wert von
millionen schweizer franken doch auch
hier bleiben die lippen versiegelt
[Musik]
entschuldigen sie die frage aber ich bin
neugierig was kostet so ein ferrari er
kostet 1,2 millionen euro
1,2 millionen euro was kostet eine für
die formel 1
etwa ein bis vier millionen euro
4 millionen meine güte
es freut uns bekanntzugeben dass die
flugstunden unseres unternehmens
erheblich gestiegen sind
dies wurde durch den einsatz unseres
neuen partners cola luckow ermöglicht
emily dodik 2012 wurde zum ersten mal
bekannt dass der milliardärin ein
schweizer unternehmen investierte rund
60 flugzeugen und landeplätzen in aller
welt ist vista jet die größte privat
flotte der welt
[Musik]
als ich mich am flughafen nach dem
unternehmer erkundigte sagte man mir er
fliege häufig mit vista jet li wies
titel
nein
[Musik]
lasst sie legal das offizielle büro der
fluggesellschaft war seit jahren in
diesem unscheinbaren gebäude im kanton
zug acquando ali bei meiner ankunft
erfurt jedoch dass die firma gerade erst
nach malta umgezogen war sie sowieso
leer die märkte
so mach hier finden sich keine hinweise
auf cola logo
[Musik]
der große vorteil von vista jet liegt
darin dass sie sich den anforderungen
der jeweiligen region anpassen können
sie haben erfahrung im nahen osten
ebenso wie in malaysia und bieten
individualisierte dienstherren
das gilt ebenso für nigeria
das kerngeschäft dieses milliardärs ist
er und einige seiner geschäftspartner
haben verbindungen zu zwei
nigerianischen firmen von energie und
atlantic energy
hat neben nigeria auch eine zweigstelle
in zürich 7
[Applaus]
[Musik]
guten morgen wo finden wir atlantic
energy
das weiß ich nicht
vielleicht
haben sie mal jemand gesehen ich hab
nicht jemanden von ihnen getroffen
und sich hier sind ist das büro leer
[Musik]
das ist die zweigstelle von atlantic
energy in zürich kein schreibtisch keine
computer debatte sicht sollte darauf hin
dass hier jemand arbeiten würde ohne
therapie ein ganzes luxuriöses stockwerk
am zürcher serie mit kosten in
millionenhöhe
[Musik]
beliebtes atlantik energie überhaupt
noch wie sieht es denn aus sind möbel da
nein keine möbel mann sind sie ihre
aussagen
ehrlich gesagt habe ich nie jemanden von
ihnen gesehen
dann ist das büro hier seit einem jahr
an die zweite stelle gibt es seit einem
jahr und niemand war jeder
atlantik energy dort sie suchen sie
manchmal packen sie hier sie sahen
afrikanischen sie kamen und gingen
schnell wieder aber offiziell sind sie
nie umgezogen
trotz des büros in zürich ist celtic
energy beim handelsregister im kanton
zug eingetragen offiziell wird die firma
gerade abgewickelt und alu co ist nicht
dass anteilseigner aufgeführt comedia
wir finden einen anderen
verantwortlichen der firma oskar um
wäsche und besuchen ihn bei sich zu
hause
[Musik]
wo finde ich den herrn special
sagt mir nichts ich runter drüben
[Musik]
als ich die adresse finde kann ich kaum
glauben dass der vorstandsvorsitzende
der million firma atlantic energy in
diesem bescheidenen wohnblock am
stadtrand leben sollen
niemand zu hause
[Musik]
gehen würden
entschuldigen sie kennen sie familien
bäche und ihrer familie
gehört
sie sollten in der zweier ohne
kenne ich nicht ja ich gut vielen dank
[Musik]
guten morgen ich suche sachen energy ich
bin vom schweizer fernsehen und wollte
mich erkundigen ob ich jemand von seven
entschied treffen könnte
ist das hier das hauptbüro von energy
will ich hier richtig
gut können sie mir wenigstens die
telefonnummer von herrn cola logo geben
dazu weiß ich nichts
hier seht ihr das hauptbüro von southern
energy der anderen ölfirma unseres
milliardärs ist in london
auch hier ist die internationale
zweigstelle eines milliardenschweren
unternehmens nur ein kleines büro im
vierten stock eines viktorianischen
gebäude aus jena palazzo mit realen
juni katastrophe sich hier trifft man
nur eine sekretärin die zu meiner
überraschung noch nie von cola luckow
gehört hat nun am 1 handy tabakladen in
london gründete luckow sogar eine
wohltätige stiftung unter seinem namen
während ich nach ihr sucht er reichlich
einen ehemaligen berater der stiftung am
telefon minister von beziehung
[Musik]
ich habe herrn luke nur zweimal
getroffen er sagte er wollte dieses
projekt verfolgen weil er nigerianer sei
und wie man so sagt etwas zurückgeben
möchte
er wollte einen teil seines geldes
seines privatvermögens an bedürftige
nigerianische jugendliche abgeben
das war das erklärte großmütige und edle
ziel der stiftung
was noch alles dahinter steckt weiß ich
nicht er hatte den kontakt zu cola
luckow verloren ich erfahre bei dem
gespräch dass die stiftung ihren
offiziellen sitz in liechtenstein hat
und trotz ihres kometenhaften erfolges
nie auch nur einen dollar an wohltätige
zwecke spendete
die politiker sind sehr korrupt aber
worin lagen die probleme existierte die
stiftung nur ein jahr lang
allem anschein nach hatte die stiftung
eine eröffnungsveranstaltung in london
dann brach zeitweise alle kommunikation
ab
wohl wegen des regierungswechsels und
des skandals bezüglich der öl
konzessionen in nigeria
[Musik]
vor 2010 steinkohle loco nie im
rampenlicht
dann wurde er auf wundersame weise zu
einem mächtigen ölbaron weil er die
richtigen verträge mit seven energy und
atlantic energy abgeschlossen hatte
[Musik]
mitten in london treffe ich eine
nigerianische anti korruptions
aktivisten der im auftrag verschiedener
nichtregierungsorganisationen
nachforschungen zu diesem fall
angestellt hat statt der owners were den
schallaburg oder der rede seines
berichts an die britische
staatsanwaltschaft geriet einer der
womöglich größten geldwäsche fälle der
welt in die schlagzahl liga jährige
claudio
progressiven energy diente dazu große
geldmengen verschieben zu können
das geld war eigentlich für den staat
bestimmt gelangte aber in private hände
diese ableitung von geldern wäre ohne
die mitwirkung einflussreiche
regierungsbeamter nicht möglich gewesen
es ist also klar dass cola luckow allem
anschein zum trotz nur eine marionette
ist
wieder der eigentümer noch der
begünstigte der firma
aktivist berichtet von einem betrug der
2010 begann als das staatliche
ölunternehmen nigerias lizenzen an
privatunternehmen vergab
alle gingen ohne ausschreibung an die
firmen southern energy und atlantik
energy welche verbindungen mit cola logo
aufweisen
die gründe für diese wahl sind nach wie
vor ein rätsel
atlantic energy die lizenz erhielt die
firma völlig inaktiv
sie bestand auch erst seit zwei monaten
selben energie war ebenfalls in eine
scheinfirma mit schleierhaft der
finanzgeschichte
darüber hinaus sieht sollte nicht
unerwähnt bleiben dass beide firmen rein
gar nichts für die lizenzen bezahlt hat
das geld aus der ölförderung sollte in
die staatskasse fließen er wurde jedoch
woanders hin geschmuggelt
so verschwanden hunderte millionen
dollar
es liegen drei rechtsgutachten vor denen
zufolge diese absprachen
verfassungswidrig und illegal sind
2014 gelangte der fall in nigeria an die
öffentlichkeit in einer live übertragung
berichtete der leiter der zentralbank
das 20 milliarden dollar aus der
staatskasse fehlten
er verwies auf unrechtmäßige absprachen
zwischen dem staatlichen ölunternehmen
und ins bei privatunternehmen cola alu
guss die vorwürfe treffen die
ölministerium schwer
noch einmal darauf hin dass es
verschiedene auffassungen bezüglich der
rechtmäßigkeit oder unrechtmäßigkeit in
dieser angelegenheit gibt
die damalige ministerin war die sunny
alison madrid gegen die aktuell wegen
des verdachts auf veruntreuung von
geldern und aufgrund anderer vorwürfe in
großbritannien ermittelt
als marionette der ministerin und auch
andere hochrangige regierungsfunktionäre
stehen unter verdacht
darunter auch der ehemalige
nigerianische präsident john f
meine rückkehr nach lugano verschaffe
ich mir noch mal einen überblick die
dynamik der angelegenheit ist das
schreckt ihn simple
die ministerin und ihre komplizen
schmuggeln die milliardenschweren
gewinne aus den ölfeldern ans ausland in
der praxis vergab der staatlichen
nigerianischen öls unter kontrolle der
ministerin acht lizenzen an seven energy
und atlantic energy
das geld aus der ölförderung das vor
meisten die staatskasse geflossen wäre
verschwand in den tresoren der beiden
firmen machen unserem land wurden
offenbar milliarden gewaschen
hallo ich bin eine journalistin von rsa
das sieht die majestät wochen warte ich
auf einen rückruf des bürgermeisters
sergej kirow co jetzt hat er seine
steuern
ohne hoffnungen mache ich mich auf den
weg zum rathaus unweit der villa des
ölmilliardärs sieht rabatt nokia siebte
bürgermeister ist nicht da aber ich kann
mit ihm telefonieren
ich weiß nicht inwieweit sie bescheid
wissen
das betrifft sie nicht persönlich wohl
aber ihre stadtgemeinde
ich glaube dass diese person
ich verstehe dass sie den datenschutz
beachten müssen
und dass sie kein interesse an den
geschehnissen haben
es geht um geldwäsche in milliarden-höhe
um milliarden von dollar
es interessiert sie als stadtverwaltung
nicht
ich nehme also zur kenntnis dass es sie
nicht interessiert und bedanke mich
vielmals
[Musik]
ich will die auswirkungen der korruption
mit eigenen augen sehen kabine causes
sehen was sie bedeutet in einem der
korruptesten länder der welt zu leben
das über jahre systematisch ausgebeutet
wurde und so im schatten luxuriöser
bauten millionen menschen hunger leiden
so
[Musik]
es ist nicht meine erste reise nach
afrika und doch zeigt sie wie verheerend
die auswirkungen sind ikonen kommunisten
auf dem papier ist in gera aufgrund des
öls laut ökonomen das reichste land
afrikas doch 120 millionen menschen 70
prozent der bevölkerung leben hier von
weniger als zwei dollar am tag
kaum zu glauben dass sich in einem land
das hunger leidet niemand für cola logos
milliarden interessiert
korruption macht die menschen ärmer
macht alle nigerianer ärmer die
stromversorgung bricht weg man kann sich
kombinieren die gaspreise müssen in
nigeria sogar angehoben werden nach
obwohl und bevölkerung leidet auch in
diesem moment während wir hier reden
was hält die allgemeinheit von der
ehemaligen ministerin die fa nie und
ihrem strom an cola luckow
sie werden als bayer wahrgenommen die
dem land ressourcen und geld gestohlen
und damit millionen nigerianern
geschadet haben im ausland bequem
erleben zu können
sie sind das gegenteil von patriotisch
da sie sich daran bereichern andere die
in extremer armut leben auszunutzen
[Musik]
im ölsektor ist die korruption am
schlimmsten
er gilt als der schnellste weg zum
großen geld und die bestbezahlte arbeit
nigerias
dies manche gehälter liegen sogar über
dem globalen durchschnitt alle wendungen
werden
sogar einige minister und abgeordnete
haben sich auf diesem weg ölfelder
gesichert um sie selbst zu
bewirtschaften oder an freunde
weiterzugeben
man kann auf diese weise reicher werden
als so mancher staat während man
millionen nigerianern schadet
[Applaus]
ich wollte nach süden ins nigerdelta
fahren wo die ölfelder der firmen von
cola luckow liegen doch es ist unmöglich
werden meines aufenthalts kam es zu
mehreren angriffen auf öl-pipelines
letztendlich liegt die größte
machtkonzentration jedoch in der
hauptstadt wo diese erschreckende
betrugsfall einst seinen ausgang nahm
die frau die
vor etwas über einem jahr kam eine neue
gruppierung mit dem ziel der bekämpfung
von korruption an die macht in norwalk
der neue präsident ist entschlossen die
milliarden die cola luckow und seine
partner veruntreut hatten zurückzuholen
analog von anderen personen sowie
vermuteten scheinfirmen wurden
geldwäsche veruntreuung und
wirtschaftsverbrechen gegen nigeria
vorgeworfen
so steht es in der verfügung mit der
seine mittel eingefroren worden
außerdem steht dort dass diese mittel
aus staatlichen geldern standen
während meines aufenthalts er liest ja
nigerianische gerichtshof eine verfügung
durch die cola aluguss finanzen weltweit
eingefroren wurden von den usa bis nach
großbritannien und in die schweiz
insgesamt 1,7 milliarden dollar deal
ist entschied auch dutzende bank konten
bei schweizer kreditinstituten mit
insgesamt 67 millionen franken
58 luxusautos drei private chats und ein
grundstück mit 2000 quadratmetern in
montagnola interessieren
collina d'oro montagnola
die gerichtliche verfügung ist weltweit
anerkannt und friert all seine mittel
ein
sowohl jene die in nigeria liegen als
auch werte im ausland in der schweiz
sind betroffen einschließlich denen in
montagnola
wir erwarten dass cola luckow sich
kooperativ zeigt und die gelder zurück
gibt die in die schweiz gebracht worden
wir fordern die rückgabe von der lupus
investitionen in der schweiz
die schweiz war zugegeben sehr
entgegenkommend aber wir hoffen uns noch
mehr kooperation und die bedingungslose
rückgabe aller mittel
guten morgen
wir hatten beim letzten mal darüber
gesprochen wie kulant bei ihnen gekauft
hat
ich rufe den bürgermeister von collina
d'oro an und frage was sie bezüglich der
beantragten beschlagnahmung des landes
in montagnola zu tun gedenken
sie wissen es noch nicht
es war eine zeit wurde es schon im
stadtrat besprochen
sie wissen von nichts es ist aber
wichtig es geht um werte die in der
schweiz beschlagnahmt werden sollen
sie sind mit alptransit ausgelastet
[Musik]
ein problem besteht darin dass westliche
länder oft uns für die rückgabe von
werten zur kasse bitten
sie sagen dann es hat eben seinen preis
manchmal sind wir entrüstet wenn sie 20
prozent oder mehr verlangen
ein bericht der weltbank hat bestätigt
dass nur ein kleiner teil der
geschmuggelten werte wieder ins
ursprungsland zurückgeht da die
industriestaaten das geld mit allen
mitteln gehalten
sie veranstalten konferenzen und
beschließen die richtigen resolutionen
doch ihr handeln ist nie hilfreich es
ist an der zeit das zu ende
[Musik]
im kampf gegen die korruption war die
internationale gemeinschaft viel zu
lange untätig
und
die internationale gemeinschaft muss bei
der rückführung geschmuggelter werte
jedoch helfen wir gehen davon aus dass
wir durch illegale machenschaften in der
ölbranche jedes jahr sieben milliarden
dollar verlieren
[Applaus]
am 10 mai 2016 haben der präsident
nigerias am internationalen anti
korruptions gipfel teil
bei dem treffen gab es wie üblich viele
absichtserklärungen
unter den gästen fand sich sogar die
aussenminister der schweiz die je
burkhalter
und doch wenn das geld weiterhin zu uns
fließt und das tut es müssen wir alles
in unserer macht stehende tun um das
geld den rechtmäßigen eigentümern
zurückzugeben ist die tui bietet die
migros den bevölkerungen dieser
entwicklungsländer
was werden die finanzsysteme der
industriestaaten tun um nigerianer bei
der rückführung dieser jahren zu helfen
wie wollen sie verhindern dass dies in
zukunft wieder geschieht
am maschine der welt am rande des
gipfels treffe ich einen analysten der
die auswirkungen der korruption of
nigeria genau kennt
er hält die westliche finanzindustrie
für scheinheilig
eine verringerung der korruption könnte
das bruttoinlandsprodukt bis 2030 und
bis zu 2000 dollar pro einwohner erhöhen
die wichtigste frage hierbei ist welche
rolle die internationale finanz branche
in dieser angelegenheit spielt
[Musik]
selbst geld zu schmuggeln ist schwierig
wenn man geld in der schweiz haben
möchte braucht man finanzpartner hat in
diesem transfer erleichtern
leider glaube ich dass wir wenn wir tief
genug graben erfahren würden dass viele
partner in industrienationen derartige
transaktionen nur zu gerne ohne die
notwendige kontrolle durchführen
anscheinend fehlt im westen der
politische wille gegen die
finanzdienstleister zu ermitteln die mit
seven energy zusammengearbeitet haben
wäre zum einen eine behörde der weltbank
und ein form der fast ausschließlich von
europäischen behörden finanziert wird
die eigentliche überprüfen müssen auf
ihre investitionen für legitime zwecke
genutzt werden
[Musik]
es gibt bezüglich all dieser
internationalen investoren von seven
energy bedenken
wollen sie sicherstellen dass seven
energy die verträge rechtmäßig erhalten
hatte
ich wandte mich mit diesen bedenken an
die investoren von energy bekam jedoch
keine antwort
die schweizer banken die in der
beschlagnahmung anordnung genannt wurden
schwiegen ebenso wie die firma die
schweizer aufsichtsbehörde
ich werde wohl nie erfahren wie viele
millionen oder gar milliarden in der
schweiz für kohle aluko gewaschen wurden
[Musik]
guten morgen ich suche einen etwa 2000
quadratmeter großes grundstück das
wusste hier in montagnola an einer
nigerianischen ölmagnaten verkauft
worden sein
wissen sie wo ich es finden kann
montagnola in montagnola ja
doch gut wenn jemand geld hat und es
ausgibt
es braucht schließlich angebot und
nachfrage
kennst du dieses grundstück in
montagnola
es muss riesig sein ei der
amerikanischen schule
[Musik]
hier weiter
im sommer finde ich das von alu co in
montagnola gekaufte land
ein haus mit 2000 quadratmetern und
blick auf den luganersee
wer weiß wie viele investitionen
unbehelligt in unserem land getätigt
wurden
trotz eines internationalen rechtshilfe
gesuchs in bern gab es in der schweiz
kein verfahren gegen den öl magnaten
ende juli war die villa in pausa
verlassen
keine spur mehr von cola logo oder seine
milliarden
[Musik]
er muss für seine taten verantworten
wenn er sich verteidigen können aber
wenn nicht aus dem recht folge geleistet
und gerechtigkeit geschaffen werden
[Musik]
ein drittel des geldes hätte die
schulbildung von tausende nigerianer von
der grundschule bis zur mittelstufe
sichern können ohne dass sie einen cent
hätten ausgeben
man hätte in jedem nigerianischen
bundesstaat ein modernes krankenhaus
bauen können und dazu 1000 kilometer
straßen
[Musik]
wir verlangen fakten und fordern die
bedingungslose rückgabe aller werte um
die serie aus der armut zu helfen
die
[Musik]